There are several consequences of using a singleton pattern.
One of the benefits is, you provide controlled access.
The only way to get access to the singleton instance is through that, that class
operation. This has the potential of reducing problems with the names,
the program name space. In particular, the alternative would be to have one or
more global variables that refer to the instance.
Once you've got global variables, they can be copied, and, and, and
referenced. Thereby leading to potential problems. Because singleton is a class,
it can be subclassed, which gives you additional flexibility. And if you were so
inclined, you wanted to have a, a class in which there could be
exactly two instances or three instances or four instances, whatever.
Okay, you could take the basic idea of the singleton and adjust it accordingly.